guys we got the dates for 2023 locked
maybe a couple more added San Diego
California I'll be back at the La Hoya
Comedy Store October 20th through the
22nd Salt Lake City I'll be headed your
way October 27th and 28th bavia Illinois
November 10th and 11th and closing out
the year at Cobbs in San Francisco
California December 8th and 9th get all
tickets at
ryanr I'm excited to announce that my
special Lefty sun is now available as an
audio album go check it out everywhere
you get
music I'm very excited to announce that
the Honeydew video is now available on
Spotify it doesn't change anything for
you at all it's just an additional place
to watch the Honeydew go check out the
Honeydew audio and video now available
on
Spotify the Honeydew with ran
[Music]
[Applause]
sichler welcome back to the honey do
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pant Studios I am Ryan sickler
ryan.com and ran sickler on all your
social media I want to say thank you
thank you to everyone who subscribes to
this show thank you to everyone who
supported my special if you haven't seen
it go watch it on my YouTube Lefty son
um and look if you got to have more then
you got to check out our patreon our
patreon is the Honeydew with y'all and
y'all have the wildest stories it never
ends all right we we talked to a dude
who had a double lung transplant we've
talked to people who solved cold cases
people who have two [__] three asses
like we have talked we've run the gamut
here okay a lot of things going on with
y'all out there and um you got to check
it out it's five bucks a month if you
are someone you know has one of these
wild stories that has to be heard please
submit it to honeydew podcast gmail.com
hopefully you'll get to do an episode
together if you're looking for a new
podcast to listen to I'm telling you go
listen to my old podcast to crab Feast
it's a 7 and 1/2 year Library Audio Only
and it's everyone you know and love in
podcasting they're all there with
different great stories all right come
see me on tour if I'm in your city when
you're around uh let's see we got
Phoenix Arizona September 29th and 30th
we're coming to La Hoya October 20th to
the 22nd I'll be in Salt Lake City
October 27th 28th bavia Illinois
November 10th the 11th and San Francisco
closing out the year December 8th
through the 9th all all tickets are
available at Ryan sickler now that's the
biz you guys know what we're doing over
here we're highlighting the low lights I
always say these stories are the stories
behind the storytellers and I'm very
excited to have this guest back on here
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome Tom
sagoro welcome back to the Honeydew Tom
sagoro good to be back good to be back I
like the new studio man you're like a
son to me man thank you you're like a
son to me
man thank you uh will you please I'm
looking at the scar on your arm let me
look at that for a
second that's [__] long dude it's
longer and then there's another one
that's oh that's not connected all the
way oh that's two you should Bridge it
bro there's another one there you should
definitely do it put a little Bridge
tiniest little Bridge like a Key West
Bridge going over another surgery coming
up why because there's still uh a nerve
issue in in here it's in the groove of
the bicep and is it painful yeah it's
painful when when C when I do certain
basically if I was like I don't want to
I don't care to do any activities I
wouldn't do it but I'm pretty active and
I do a bunch of different things and I I
get it fired up when I do them and he
was like how important is it for you to
address I was like yeah I would like to
do these things without pain yeah
without pain yeah I have this whole new
thing since the surgery down my neck
into my shoulder down my right arm and
down into my right shoulder blade
numbness and pain and all originates
from the spine cuz everything of course
it does spal sur got all [__] up arm
and hand stuff shoulder stuff it's all
from the from the SP so the spinal
surgeon's like we're going to do your
lumbar MRI and we'll do a neurological
one on that area back there Blue Shield
silver go [__] yourself has
denied that MRI they have completely
denied it so the surgeon's like don't
worry we'll we'll do a peer-to-peer with
them we'll get it cleared they [__]
flat out denied the peer-to-peer said I
have to appeal it I have to go through
this whole process to appeal a doctor's
professional suggestion I get an MRI to
see why I'm in pain and I'm assuming
it's because probably like you I'm
immediately in January I was out of
pocket and everything was covered you
know what I mean and now they're doing
everything they can not to cover that
[__] sure of course you know like we're
in August let's see if we can't bleed
thisal January that's probably what it
is it's a whole science of my scar is
longer than I thought it would be but
that's a while will that get any better
over time no I don't think so I mean
there you know what at first they gave
you this like they have like a
state-of-the-art silicone gel that
you're supposed to put on your scarf
like every day to what make it like it
reduces like the way that you know the
Coco butter do the same thing look yeah
and uh I did it like twice I was like
whatever um I don't care I wouldn't care
yeah I mean every time somebody like
when people are like where's that Scar
from I always go like two tours
Afghanistan they're like really no um
all right let's get into what we're
going to talk about before we do plug
everything please whatever you want um
yeah you know special special uh
Sledgehammer the newest ones on Netflix
um what's it what else I mean there's
podcasts every week on the ymh studios
YouTube channel and you got new On's out
right now first date we launched first
date we we launched not today pal um we
got a couple other ones coming that uh
haven't announced yet yeah and then
um yeah I'm I'm doing dates but like
just a few here and there I'll announce
a 2024 tour are going to go back on tour
yeah but I'm going to do it like I'm
going to announce it like probably in
November and it's something that'll
start in like J late January February
something like that and go through the
spring nothing nothing like the last one
though no well I might do I might tour
for a few years on it but I'm I'm not
going to do it as aggressively every
week no no no yeah that's crazy dude
it's [__] stupid um well I want to
talk to you cuz I you and I have only
talked a little bit about it but I
really do want want to talk to you about
your Dad's passing and and what's you
know where you're at with that now and
stuff because you are gone non-stop yeah
um and I know like it goes back to at
least for you and I we were talking
about when your dad was sick I believe
at the time he was going to Minnesota
was it some clinics he was going to see
him yeah so the funny thing was is that
like when it
started he
was trying to get all the timing right
he was
diagnosed in 20
18 the day like the week before he
retired like yeah he worked for 40 four
years whatever and then we had his
retirement party like he had all these
people came in town that like he knew in
family and then the day after his
retirement party was his first chemo
treatment so that was yeah but when did
he find out he had it when did they give
him the notice a little bit before the
official retirement and then they're
like you need to get on chemo and they
started chemo the day so he's like time
to start retirement and in day one was
chemo so that that was pretty like he
like you like cuz all he was like
talking about leading up to retirement
was like the things he wants to do like
can't wait to be retired I'm going to go
spend time with my grandkids travel he
had this [__] he goes he would say
the same thing to me like in the months
leading up he was like your mother and I
are very excited about this next chapter
and I was like uhuh I was like what are
you gonna do he's like you know your
mother's never seen Vermont
Maine uh the Grand Canyon and I was like
does she give a [__] about that
and your mom I don't give a [__] about
defer things like I sat next door her at
that dinner she wanted chicken nuggets
yeah she was so he goes you know what
we'll do is we'll just get in the car
and we'll just drive and there's no
schedule so we can just stop
somewhere spend the night like a Red
Roof in and then just drive I go you're
going to put this 7 [__] foury old
woman just on road trips so here's the
thing he was he was sold on it as like
this is an awesome plan and then one day
he's told me about this like 20 times
I'm like sitting with my mom and he's
over here and I go are you really like
you're excited about all these road
trips like you're going to just be on
the road driving for months seeing
[__] Vermont and she was like what
and he goes yeah you know I'll show you
all these places she was like I don't
want to do this never you never told her
the idea he's like well I just thought I
thought I'd take her hostage that's what
he thought and then she's like what
about the
dogs he's like we'll find places that
can she goes I don't want to do a road
trip every day like that's he was just
talking about going out for like six
months in a car too not no just like sit
there sit on the highway Park sleep and
then he's like here's
Maine here's M she just like oh cool she
doesn't give a [__] about that Char
don't give a [__] about no way dude
seeing any of those places she's a
horrible tra by the way real quick I
have to say this I couldn't get a
picture of her they wouldn't let it
happen or anything it was she was very
protective but the real not the real Let
me take it back the earlier Charro yeah
was on my flight um you know coochie
whatever Charo Char the the first one
not you try to take a picture of her
well everyone was trying to get a little
picture or and they like no no no no no
I was like oh God please let me get this
Charro picture I couldn't get a Charro
recently yeah just like a few months
ago yeah I don't see that happening
which I wonder which one will die first
between the two
Char I can't believe they're both still
around weigh in everybody who's dying
first the Char or
Char I bet you the other Char would have
loved that dinner you [__] took us to
your mother hated that just to give
people some like I like Chick-fil-A we
took her to a Michelin Three Star this
is the type of restaurant where if
you're following the Michelin guide
they're saying it's worth it to take a
trip if you're taking a road trip with
your dad it's worth it to beer off on
the way to me saying it's worth to make
a trip just to eat here just to eat here
eat here and it was like I mean it was
an experience right it was an experience
and everything she would just like take
this she goes Eat This and like knock it
onto your plate you're like the [__] no
she wouldn't do that I would eat my
plate and clean it then she would take
my plate put it in front of her slide
hers over make me look like and then say
literally say to me the least you could
do is eat your food my son is paying a
lot of money for this she would say as
they were taking my food you pie of yeah
psycho she's done that [__] to me so
many times where like she goes M I thank
you so much and then she just knocks it
on the my plan what do you do she's like
eat it I'm like you eat it yeah yeah no
she wants fries french fries chicken
fingers she eats like a toddler yeah and
then she eats Starburst sometimes eat
them yeah if you go you go by in her bed
in the like on the nightstand you find
like like 16 Starburst rappers she like
the [__] did you you ate those before
bed yeah she's like I can't stop I can't
stop I
and then she eats bread uh paneton which
is like that sweet Italian bread or
toast with jam and woman weighs [__]
big she weighs you know 115 I think um
hasn't gained weight since she got
married 46 seven years that's crazy it's
really and then doesn't exercise doesn't
take care of herself doesn't eat
anything like nutritious at all and then
she'll be like I I'm just I'm diet I'm
like yeah go maybe try going for a walk
and she's like I'll show you this year
how I'm going to take turn things around
like okay turn them around she's in Dire
Straits over there it's like always the
same so your dad's just goal was to just
kind of chill then and just yeah he was
so excited he was so excited about it
there was the retirement party did you
ever talk to him about that like [__]
you work your whole life and then I mean
party the retirement we have a set date
we already know when that's happening
then he gets the news before that it was
no yeah cuz the the retire I remember it
was November of 2018 is this in
Florida yeah MH brother came
in sister came in um nieces nephews
cousins friends like people he worked
with you know 30 years ago in Ohio 25
years ago in Minneapolis like all these
people that were like in his life they
all came in for this thing that's
awesome yeah it was very cool it was
very cool and then yeah then he starts
chemo but I had like pretty high hopes
for the treatment they said that like
what was his diagnosis multiple Myoma
and what is that it's a blood cancer so
you but is it curable for some people is
that why you had High Hopes no it's not
actually curable and it also doesn't
it's not what kills you you don't die
from multiple Myoma you die from like
other you know like what it causes your
body yeah you end up having a heart
attack or you know you get the flu but
like you don't actually die from
multiple
Myoma so the big thing though that they
try to get people to do with multiple
myom is get a bone marrow transplant and
and so like you know one of the best
places to do this is the Mayo Clinic in
Rochester Minnesota it's one of the
world's leading medical
facilities his brother
was like um a doctor there for 30 years
or also what is he the same brother that
invented the sagora thing s basket yeah
that's crazy when you told me that I was
like stop f it it does sound it sounds
made up I know what is a sagora basket
well so now it's probably kind of dated
right so I'm sure that but at the time
it was like a pretty state-of-the-art
way to remove kidney stones oh so he was
the urologist okay so yeah if you look
up cigara basket it'll you know that's
kind of like that's your dad's brother
my dad's brother yeah my dad my Uncle
Joe and he was a yeah he was a like a
world-renowned urologist like like fly
him to Italy to give a speech kind of
[__] yeah oh yeah yeah and he was really
bright um yeah and he invented that if
you if you meet a urologist and you say
it they'll be like yeah of course I know
what a cigaro basket is it'd be
hilarious if in their world they all
know your uncle and don't know you at
all you know I like sagora you know
sagora you see his last special what you
mean the Bas we piss yeah you talking
about the kidney stone guy doing C there
tells
jokes there's only one Zora okay Joe zor
I met I met I know I always think it's
so funny too like I've talked about this
extensively with like when a man's a
gynecologist or a woman is a urologist
you're like really like a female prison
guard at a male like all the things that
came up in med school you're trying to
tell me nothing interested you more than
dicks like there's or like the the EUR
the the male who's a gynecologist and
you're like are we all supposed to
[__] fall for this like that your
interest you just care about
reproductive the vagina so much you just
want to help everyone out and nothing
turned me into believing that it's
nonsense than when I was like 16 and I
hung out so my high school friend's dad
is friends with a gynecologist a male
gyne a male gynecologist who's in his
late 50s he's got this like
multi-million dollar house on the beach
and he's having a party there's like
chicks hanging out you know he's got a
gold chain white hair and I'm like this
he seen all their [__] yeah what's up
Sharon yeah and there's like girls like
making out and stuff and we're like oh
[__] yeah we're teenagers you know so
I'm like I don't know I talk to him for
a minute he's like on his
grill and I go can I ask you a question
and he's like yeah what's up I go so how
do you like how does your mind
differentiate I'm thinking I'm asking
like a very clever question I think for
a
16-year-old like this is a patient
versus this is like a woman with her
legs open and he goes he just flips a
burger and he goes pussy's [__] that's
a doctor and I was
like
okay I was expecting like a of course
some doctor yeah some medical
explanation well pussy's [__] I was
like very
[Music]
cool that's so absurd went to school for
eight years you know what I mean plus
also though let looking at this way yeah
he might have been like this is the best
thing I can ever do and then three years
in he' be like what the [__] did I do
and now he's got to do it and he's just
sick of it you know what I mean he's
seen he's not in there I remember being
in I will never forget this is so I feel
even looking back as a grown man I feel
like it's so early yeah it I will never
forget this we're in middle school it's
like seventh eighth grade yeah and the
TV show Hunter was on had Fred Dryer who
used to play for the Chargers he was
like a cop in it had this attractive
brunette that drove this Dodge Chrysler
Laser I can't remember what her name was
but she was pretty and one of our
friends Troy just out of nowhere just
goes man I'd like to be her gynecologist
and we all start laughing you know but
like and I think about it like first of
all that's very early seventh grade to
say some [__] like that and then you
start thinking about it over the years
i' because it's made me think yeah
you're not seeing the best of the you're
seeing problems you're seeing problems
issues like [__] you might have only see
one problem [__] is what you're
seeing problematic [__] yeah yeah and
you're all up in them too oh you're
you're fixing it yeah your face is right
is right into the problem [__] yes
you're not being like oh look at this
this is wonderful I went to this
reception this like honoring my uncle
mhm when he was still alive um he died
too he did as well yeah and then my
dad's younger sister died uh all within
how long well he
died Joe died like more than 10 years
ago oh he went first yeah was he the
oldest yeah yes and uh he had
um what is it mes witha I think and and
he was exposed toest and all that work
yeah um I forget where he was that he
was exposed I mean my dad was exposed
obviously to Asian orange and stuff in
Vietnam my aunt an was uh she went from
from diagnosis to dying in like 90 days
get the F of what she had a form of
leukemia didn't like she was just like I
feel tired like she went on a walk I
feel tired every
yeah she's like I feel like really tired
and they just ran a bunch of tests and
they're like you have stage four like
you're you know this is take her in and
it's during coid so like family can't
you know they start like keeping
people dies like in what do you do you
get 90
days do you just not take the chemo and
live it out or do you try to go get the
chemo and extend it a little longer
knowing what I know now and see what
I've seen I'd probably just go home and
just let it if I was that far along yeah
yeah stage four I mean yeah bad 90 days
what we going to get out of that even if
we do chemo another two months of of
horri quality at all yeah no no dude but
this I had to tell you this that um I'm
at this reception I'm like yeah yeah
[__] [__] the last thing that's when I
was 16 right now I'm
24h and I'm at this thing for my uncle
and there's all these urologists and
like my family's there and then they go
and I have that thought about when an
opposite gender their specialty is the
genitals of the other and they go this
is Dr so and so this woman um and you
know I go oh yeah what kind of what's
your special she's like oh neurologist
and I go so you like dicks and my cousin
goes Tommy like like and my dad's over
here and he
goes shakes his head he's like don't do
that and I go I'm sorry I'm sorry so the
lady kind of laughs and she's like uh I
go
I go I love them I go all right I'm
sorry about that I go but but what's
like the biggest flaccid one that you've
held and she's like uh and they just
start laughing and then she won't tell
me she wouldn't she wouldn't tell me it
had to be that big it had to be an elf
and [__] trunk or something
FL he was old too I think so probably in
his late 70s just [__] just tired of
it like here this this is what I'm
dealing with over here this thing is
causing me more problems than you would
believe
[Laughter]
no one's touching that I got dick
problems it's a horse dick yeah you know
who you can put it with in these
problematic [__] over here that's
what you should be doing real big one
over here
too that guy with the big horse the
older guy he's got to have what's it
called he's got to have a um like a
fedora I feel like a guy with he's got a
fedora let me take my head off set that
down on my dick just set it right on his
dick out here um
all right so your dad yeah back to your
dad so so he starts chemo day after the
big part and then the big thing is like
they're in Florida he's got all these
ties to the Mayo Clinic his brother my
uncle's
daughter also a doctor at the Mayo
Clinic um and he knows like it's World
re like you know it's like the best of
the best at the Mayo Clinic [__]
Saudi Kings fly to like Mayo Clinic is
that right the one in Minnesota yeah so
he's Consulting with them being treated
in Florida and then okay we're going to
do a bone marrow transplant so
historically people who get bone marrow
transplants with multiple Myoma get a
minimum of a
fiveyear life extension okay so it's
it's it and sometimes they keep living
you know Tom broka has multiple myo
still yeah oh okay it doesn't go away
like it does it's not when you replace
the bone marrow you get in remission but
you still are genetically you
predisposed to this [__] okay so he goes
up there and like you know when you have
mean you had major surgery they're like
we're doing this there's
a 1% chance that like this can go wrong
this is what they told me this is yes
I'm the yes completely understand he
gets he gets his Bello transplant goes
into septic
shock uh codes he did yeah heart stops
for 20 minutes your dad's hard stop for
205 20 minutes they do CPR I mean they
told me later they go CPR at another
medical facility or like a EMT or
something they go they would have
stopped at like 7 to 12 minutes or
something you know like but they did it
for 20 minutes at the Mayo Clinic
how I mean they just the machine just
breathing for you and his but his heart
stopped heart stopped and they just keep
trying to revive him they were trying to
revive him for 20 minutes and they
brought him back they brought him back
did you talk to before he passed did you
talk to him about
anything long time we talked a lot about
so when he's there and uh this is
before I think this is before I get
sorry I can't imagine coming to and
someone being like you died for 20
minutes and then hearing that as as the
person he also didn't remember this huge
chunk of time because he went when he
went into like
septic shock you know like your body
shuts down and he was like I went and
visited
him at one point and
um you know like his eyes moved and he
was like mouthing something but he had
tubes in and he didn't seem like seem
like 100%
there and they're like oh yeah he
doesn't know like really what's going on
or have much reference for what's
happening where he is any of that
[__] and that time he also like when I
on that trip I'm visiting him at the
Mayo Clinic it's 2019 it's like March of
2019 and he has like his stomach has
filled up with fluid like just his body
is like distended stomach like he's in
this bed and I'm like why is his stomach
so big and they're like those fluid is
just building up so doing like stomach
draining it's crazy and like I know
there's 20 tubes like you know you're
seeing like what is this exiting out of
this tube it's like black you know like
just all kinds of things going on with
him sideways and that's when like the
doc one of the doctors pull me aside and
he was like he was like Hey man pussy's
[__]
[Laughter]
[__] and I was like you're the second
doctor that said
that he's like I've been looking at it
like done true I'm sorry this hospital
is full of
it there's so much not top shelf [__]
here right now so this is the guy that
has to pull you aside and give you the
bad news this dud he basically goes He
how do he say it with without saying it
he tells me your dad's probably gonna
die right now is what he you know what I
mean now yeah cuz I'm there and I'm
visiting I like my mom and my sister I I
get them I get them all an apartment cuz
I know he's going to be there for a
while I get them an apartment in
Rochester um and like in Rochester gets
so
cold uh that like yeah they say they
have three Winters there they it's
connected tunnels right so that like
when you instead of like going from your
apartment to the hospital um like like
you would just walk over there it's all
connected yeah yeah so you take your
elevator down and then there's just a
tunnel you never have to go outside
especially because there's so many
patients there you
know so
When I visit I'm like I I was in I think
New York I fly to Rochester
Minnesota and I'm like I'm coming to I
don't realize the shape that he's in at
this
time I'm like oh my God uh and that I
see like how sick he is because it's
much worse than I I had imagined and
they're like yeah just everything that
could go wrong like you with you you
know in a s like it went everything has
gone wrong like he's you know body
didn't take to the foreign you know uh
entities entering and and like they
rejected things and he got septic you
know like the worst infection you can
get like and then you're trying to beat
an infection while somebody has a
vulnerable system it's like so let me
ask you about bone marrow is that like
um it's delicious it is I had it with
you in uh Iowa where were we that night
that [__] and he was like 14 remember
that Chef came out of the back he's like
I don't know just just [__] around at
home we like thaty amazing that was
amazing yeah that was that restaurant
that's connected to pedmont Stakes I
think yeah and he stayed open for you
and it was so [__] good that's the
best B marrow I've ever had in my life
yeah it was one of the best meals I've
ever had was it was Iowa wasn't it yeah
yeah um wait is it Iowa or was
it Nebraska wasn't it wasn't it Lincoln
cuz I feel like I can't remember cuz I
feel like Lincoln was really bad weather
that night and it was a fire LA and we
did Lincoln and got right the hell on
the plane and got out of there I don't
know it's so you know how it is there so
many of them in a row I can't remember
but yeah but I wanted to ask you bow do
you have to be a match or anything like
that or is it just good question is it
like blood where you just have to have
that type or whatever I don't remember I
honestly don't remember I I used to know
this and it's like I'm just curious how
extensive that is I used to know this
and and it definitely has left my my
mind now I don't remember the farmer's
dog was founded by two dog lovers who
decided to reimagine imagine pet food
from the ground up in the 5 years since
they delivered their first meal the
response has been incredible the
farmer's dog aspires to grow another the
world's leading Pet Health and Wellness
brand and they can't do that without dog
lovers like you the farmer's dog makes
and delivers fresh healthy dog food it's
developed by vets nutritionally balanced
and made from real healthy ingredients
to human food safety standards it's the
best option for dogs at all life stages
because it's not kibble it's not canned
goods it's just real healthy food
traditional dry and wet dog food options
are highly processed they can use much
lower quality ingredients than they
claim to and they're extremely difficult
to portion accurately look princess ly
Rose loves it let me show you what else
I like about them Farmers dogs the bomb
look they tailor everything this ISS
Princess Lily Rose's chicken recipe all
right and it's on every one of her meals
this says Princess Lily Rose's feeding
guide everything's spelled properly I
can't get my vet to get her name right
all right so here's the deal get 50% off
your first box of of fresh healthy food
at thefarmersdog.com honeydo plus you
get free shipping just go to farmers.com
honeydo to get 50% off that's Farmers
do.com honeydo y'all it's time to talk
about your kitchen we all know you've
been making egg sandwiches in a torn-up
witches cauldron you call a pan since
College today's sponsor hexclad has
revolutionized the cookware industry
with a hybrid pan that gives you all the
convenience and cleanup of non-stick the
versatility of your grandma's cast iron
and they're so durable they literally
last a lifetime we're serious they have
a lifetime warranty just in case you
find a way to destroy them hexclad
patented laser etched hexagonal steel
ridges boost your searing power while
the nonstick valleys contain its
high-grade non-toxic coating and are
infused with diamond dust for extra
toughness hexclad truly checks every
single box when it comes to picking your
cookware they are metal utensil safe
their dishwasher safe and oven safe up
to 500° they are non-toxic induction
ready and even have a stay cool handle
so you can sauté with these here's the
other thing I just got mine I already
seasoned them washed them with a soap
and water put some olive oil in them for
a few minutes you cook on low medium
heat on these they're not you don't need
high heat on these pans they heat evenly
they distribute the heat evenly and you
can also put them in the oven too up to
500° and I know that they didn't say it
I know it cuz I read the instructions
it's time to stop ordering delivery food
and start cooking like a big boy with
hexclad real Cuisine isn't made in the
microwave it's cooked in a hexclad for a
limited time only my listeners get 10%
off your order with my exclusive link
just go to hexclad dcom honeydo support
the show and check them out at hexclad
domcom honeydo bone Appetit let's eat
with hexads revolutionary cookware
there's no quick fix for anxiety and
depression all right it's not finding a
new therapist it's not starting a new
exercise routine it's not more and
regular meditation or a better diet
sometimes you need something to unlock
your brain a new way of thinking about
and seeing the world and maybe that
thing is guided ketamine therapy for
mind Bloom there's a new tool to improve
your mental health it's atome ketamine
therapy mind Bloom is the leader in at
home ketamine therapy having safely
helped thousands of people overcome
their anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
anti-depressants in a study of over
1,200 mind Bloom clients 89% reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only two sessions right
now mind Bloom is offering my listeners
$100 off your first six session program
when you sign up at mind bloom.com
honeydo and use promo code honeydew take
the first step and break free from your
anxiety and your depression with mind
Bloom mind bloom.com honeydo and use
promo code honeydew now let's get back
to the D okay so they everything's gone
wrong that could the doctor he you know
he goes he did what your dad did when
you said do you like this he just went
yeah he was like yeah he goes cuz my
sisters were like my my younger sister
and my mom they were so in it like every
day that they they they were like very
emotional about things and they couldn't
like you know they were like don't lift
his head up when you do the that tube he
doesn't like that and the doctor is like
looking at me and I was like I I did the
thing where I was like I you know of
course ignore them like they don't know
they think
they're telling you something he's like
yeah we have to move his head I go no I
know like just do it and don't tell them
and you know cuz they were like no like
we know and I was like they don't know
so then I was like so what's what are
you going to do next and he was like
well he started to go like kind of like
nod like I could talk to you right I'm
like yeah he's like do everything we can
man sorry like it's not much take him
down try to do this without operating
blah blah I mean it the message was
there it was like I don't think this is
going to go well and I was like
okay shortly after like I'm in this like
uh patient family room I break down cry
because I know he's about it's like I
believe he's about to die I cry like
really hard I um I'm with my mom I cry
really hard with her and I was just like
you know I had to get back to my family
so I said goodbye and I was like I knew
that the next call was going to be he
died and that like that was like March
like March April
2019 I don't know how he [__] made it
out of there yeah I remember you telling
me I called and check you're like he's
he's doing a lot better and he went back
to Florida didn't he like left there
yeah so I flew to Rochester and flew him
home yeah I flew him home from from
Minnesota what and it just they can't
even explain it either just something
happened where it took all of a sudden
he well he he the big problem was he had
to beat this infection like you know he
he had the transplant but the transplant
had so many complications so once the
body can beat that infection and he can
start to get stronger he did he didn't
yeah and and was able to beat the how
long after they gave you the news that
he might not he's not going to probably
make it here how long I thought every
day he was going to be dead
and
then pretty like the next thing they
told me I remember was that he was out
of it and like not you know not moving
like a ICU patient for like 17 days jeez
so his legs completely atrophied like he
could walk and the [__] thing is you
know like this
was they were like yeah like we found
him on the
floor like they go don't this is like
once he came to you don't walk so don't
don't get up out of bed and he was like
okay and then he was like I just felt
like walking so I got up and just
[__] fell you know like and you go
but they just said don't walk he's like
yeah I know I'm
like okay it's crazy like your parents
you're like the [__] is wrong with you
man they just said you can't walk I was
like I just felt like it and I'm like
okay so like eight [__] you know his
legs gave out but then he had to like
learn to walk again
and then he's finally like recovering
you know because then it's like back to
PT and like you know you got to build up
some leg strength and leg
muscle and he's finally like I take him
I take him at the end of that year I
believe it was the end of that year to
Hawaii for New Year take my parents
there with my kids and everything
and starts New Year and he's like I'm
real excited about this year and like
just getting out there and living life
is
2020 so like February March they're like
stay home yeah especially if you're
immuno compromised so he spent the
majority of the life he had left just
like inside with your mom just the worst
punishment being inside with my mother
like he could have just gotten that car
and drove anyway he should have just
drove into the ocean would have better
fing the we Jesus can you imagine what a
punishment that was to
spend that's how you went out that's
terrible yeah that's terrible he finally
towards the end of his life he used to
never say this up he's like at the end
of his life he's like your mom's being a
real [__] today it took him that long
he I'm about to be out of here
yeah I was like you just figured that
[Laughter]
out man but it s I mean I really it
sucked for him you know I does suck
you're going to retire and you're going
to live okay you're going to live this
life all right well now that's
abbreviated all right okay it's
abbreviated but got at least the next
couple years here I made a recovery like
you do but you don't he's going to be
stuck inside the whole time like what I
remember the one of the last things the
last I you people ask like my regret my
only regret I want ask is that I
didn't I didn't think I didn't see the
end coming like I knew that he was not
in remission anymore obviously didn't
last the 5 years it only lasted a couple
years if I could go back uh I would have
spent a lot more time with him in those
last few months you know but I was like
I remember in
August August September I go to Cabo and
Christina it's her idea I have to give
her credit she was like why I think
she's yeah she goes why don't you fly
your dad out with to be with you for a
couple days to Cabo and I was like I go
yeah I like you know I I mean I almost
didn't it's one of those things where I
was like yeah so I I reach out to him I
go what if I fly you to Cabo and um we
just hang out here for a few days and
this is SE September
of
21 yeah September of
21 and he's like it's like late August
early September you know like in that
range he's like yeah you know it's uh
you know my mom she's like I don't know
you know know it's complicated he's he's
not that comfortable he has to get I go
I'll charter a flight like I'll send a a
plane
to fly you from like basically you just
drive down the street it flies you to
Backyard yeah and then we hang out for a
few days and then it'll fly you home and
he's like really I go yeah so I do that
he gets there he gets I'm already in
Cabo and I go
I see the car pull up and you know I go
how was the flight you know you flew on
a PJ just for you he goes I thought i''d
be
bigger right away he's doesn't give a
[__] what he says at this point no I was
like cool it was neat but I thought it
be I thought it' be bigger yeah you know
what that call I Jesus Christ
neat first thing he does is order like a
double bacon cheeseburger with fries and
of course I don't realize how like think
how far along his sickness is I'm like
I'm about to say something about what
he's eating so I was like Jesus man and
then he's like have to [__] listen to
your mom and sister give me [__] about
this he start I was like it I was like
all right I'll just let that go yeah and
then we have I think the next day I do
say something I'm like yeah but you know
don't you think should like as a
recovering patient like maybe try to mix
up some healthy food of course it goes
no it's like every
conversation and it's just like okay
so hangs out a few days flies back and I
was like yeah he's not 100% but like did
he get around was he walking and stuff
fine no Walker no cane or did he have a
little something I remember I think I
want to say I want to I'm trying to
remember whether he was using it because
he did use a cane towards the end but I
don't think it was on that trip I I
don't think it was so yeah we had
dinners and like we just hang he just
like to like lounge around you know play
chest on his [__] iPad like he'd have
like 40 games going at once and
then you know flies back and I was like
that was great I was like we really had
like a good time hanging out I fly back
the next time I believe that I see him
is Thanksgiving and I fly we all go to
Florida and we're like I'm I'm at his
house and he he definitely has the
cane um but like he comes to
Thanksgiving dinner but he's doing [__]
like I I got you know instead of like
hanging out he's like I want to go back
and you're like okay but like it's kind
of in line with like an older person or
a sick person who goes like I enjoyed
the midle I'm going to go lay down I'm
like okay at one point he pulls me
aside me and my uncle and he goes just
so you know he's like this is you know
this is not going to end well this going
it's going to go south and I was like
really he goes yeah and you're going to
have to like step up and do this and
then he tells my uncle you're going to
have to do this and we're like yeah and
I'm thinking like this
is what he foresees just like down the
line so this is November it's
Thanksgiving
week one month later I
fly for Christmas for
Christmas and he um is in bed and is
definitely dying like when I get to the
house I'm like unrecognizable not
speaking like like you know gasping like
face everything is like and this is a
month and I'm like and my my sister and
Mom are so like out of it they're like
yeah you know we have the appointment on
Monday and I'm like yeah and they're
like yeah I think you know like I don't
know what treatment they're going to
suggest and I'm like
[Music]
so thrown by it I'm like huh what cuz I
realized they're just so in it sure um
they don't see it protocol yeah it's
like when somebody is in a relationship
and they don't see they can't see what
the other person's like you know they
just can't see the how sick he is
they're like yeah you know so we'll see
that guy on Monday and then hopefully
next week we'll get and I'm like this
guy is a about to die like I could
tell I was like we got to go to the
hospital and they were like what and
he's like you know he he's like I don't
want to move I'm like no you like I mean
I'm like we got to get him
there we go to the hospital I think we
go there and come back you call 911 how
do you get them I forget how I think I
forget cuz I they were kind of dialed
into all the people right right I think
I want to say that we went there and
came home and went back again like over
the course of a few days oh they let him
come home and he went back again cuz I
think he did he didn't want to be there
on Christmas so we were home and then I
was like you know I remember man it was
so sad like
when when we're in the hospital and one
of the doctors was
like yeah there's no like there's
nothing to do and I was like expecting
that mhm but my mom and my sister were
not really really they still had help
the whole way
100% 100% they were like what and
they're like yeah this is like this is a
not just like he's gonna like he's gonna
die very
soon full [__] freak
out which is like and like you know did
that surprise
you kind of not I I could see how in
mesed in all of it they were and how
hopeful they were and he had bounced
back from things so they were like he's
going to bounce back from you know then
they like pull up like scans and and
they're like just all you see is tumors
like huge tumors everywhere and then you
just see him and you're like this is not
this is way past like let's try
something
different and then um he was doing this
thing before how old was he
74 he was like they do this thing and
they said it's very common with patients
that are dying where like they're like
all right like pull me up so he'd sit up
in bed put put his feet over and he's
like I want to go like let's go he go
get the car I was like the doctor was
like he's going to do that like a
thousand times really yeah and they do
that and they do that and then he's like
help me lay back down and he lay back
down and then he'd be like help me up
set up he like go get the car I was like
what is that all about he's like um it's
like this the body he said like the the
medical staff was like it's just like
the body knows it's going to die and
it's like it's like antsy at first it's
like um like we don't want to we don't
want to yeah like they're almost like
you're resisting Mo fighting go go go
he's like but it's like people who are
dying do this wow then they have uh the
next did you know that never and I had
no idea and then like get up and let's
get out of here let's get out of here
he's like and and he just kept doing it
then they have
um they call it the death rattle which
is like that lung thing you can hear it
rattling and they're like oh yeah it's
the death
rattle um then your car they me when
they measure they can your carbon
dioxide hits a certain level they're
like oh the person's no longer conscious
you know but they're still alive and
then they're like that's kind of like
the next
state and then they're like yeah at at
that point they're like CU they would
tell you like probably going to die in a
couple days probably going to die in a
day and then they're like any minute now
they tell you like that you heard that
oh yeah they're like any minute you
heard the doctors tell your dad's about
to go any minute now was in the hospital
wasn't it home oh was Hospital yeah
hospital um and I was like okay and then
like what's that
like I mean the Mayo Clinic visit I was
much more emotional because I was
arriving and I I didn't know what I was
going to see and I was
shocked even though I was shocked to see
him when I visited for Christmas I knew
that this at this point that this was a
sick person who was no longer in
remission who was deteriorating so it
was it was less shocking also that when
I saw him the first time my first
thought was like this is a this this
person is dying so when they go hey
guess what this guy's going to die I'm
like yeah I know you know it was it was
much less shocking shocking you know you
still it's still emotional I mean I I
broke down much harder at the uh the
2019 visit at the Mayo uh the thing that
broke me hard was at his funeral service
the because he was a
marine yeah my dad they play the what is
it Taps they play that fold up the FL I
[__] broke down me too dude that one
was rough they do the 21 gun salute
listen I'm not even joking what I say I
feel like they did shoot something I
feel like seven dudes came out and fired
three times I don't think there were
21 I think the math had it up I think
there was seven dudes ex three I forget
but I can't remember I might be totally
making that up but we did get a folded
flag they present it to you it's so nice
that thing made me cry really hard yeah
that's
powerful Taps and it's just so
def [__] love the Marine Corps I mean
this guy loved the Marine Corps he would
always say this thing that now I say if
somebody's like well you know I know uh
you're a former Marine he'd go there's
no such thing as a former Marine I was
like okay so like he I mean he loved the
Marine Corps so like then these like
Marines are there and they're saluting
you and stuff and I was like oh yeah
that [__] [__] me up bad yeah yeah I
remember that [__] too my dad so this I
ask you this because I woke up to my dad
dead there was no heads up there was no
deterioration it was just like switch
sure but what I want and also at a much
younger age I was 16 when that happened
but I want to ask you this knowing what
you went through even though it was ugly
and would you rather that or would you
rather wake up to your dad's gone no
warning know anything I mean cuz you're
watching a man go from healthy it's very
very hard to watch the deterioration the
deterioration is really hard I do I am
glad I got the time I really do regret
not if I had obviously know what had
known I would have
spent September and October like I had
no idea that it was going to be sure
that
fast
um I don't know I think you just want
more time you know I don't know I dude I
can't tell you now how many times I this
I'm 50 yeah I still think of my dad
saying you want to run to Kmart with me
I'm like nah I'm going to play video
games and now yeah how much I would love
to take that [__] ride I know oh I
know like it it like the emotional stuff
like I'll be like oh I can definitely
talk about it and I get emotional over
things I don't expect like what can
be well the first one was like cuz let
me just say this yeah I got you by a lot
of years yeah and still I'll be in the
grocery store and I'll open up the
freezer section it might be a song or
something it just hit me and I just like
yeah what's happen I got to get out of
[__] room yes yeah what's caught you
by
surprise one was that so many people
have
said you know sorry and this and that
and you're like yeah and I'm like thanks
so much you know appreciate it but just
like one guy so like I had a dinner one
time and uh there was a a Navy
SEAL that was coming to dinner M and my
dad was going to come to that dinner oh
he was so I was like hey man you got to
sit next to my dad like he's gonna
[__] lose his like cuz he just loves
the military loves talking about combat
some VI like some vets could be Vietnam
or any type of it who have seen combat
do not want to talk about it for obvious
reasons and he was the opposite he was
like what do you want to know and he
would go into detail about everything it
just didn't bother him he just enjoyed
it I was like when he [__] learns
that you're a seal who and like I the
guy had already told me some combat
things I was like dude he's going to
[__] lose his
mind I mean I sat them next to each
other my dad almost didn't eat cuz he
his whole time he was like I just watch
him like [__] hurt I see him just ear
to ear that's great that's great so like
but I saw that
seal
like nine months later and I'm not
thinking anything of it and all he all
he said was like I was really sorry to
hear about your DB man I [__] BR CU
cuz it was him yeah and it just got you
yeah yeah it's crazy what I'll get you
I'll tell you one that gets me um and I
don't know if you've had this yet cuz I
have pictures of my dad everywhere yeah
and my daughter I gu Stella was probably
it's going to be hard to talk about she
was young maybe three yeah Four Tops and
um I explained to her like you know when
I grew up I didn't have grandfathers
either one was my mom's dad was already
dead and our grandfather died we were
born in 73 March he died November of 73
so never you know didn't know him
and my daughter doesn't know my dad so
there's pictures of them and I just tell
her stories all the time all the time
and then one night she grabs his picture
and she just starts crying I go why you
upset and she's like I miss my
grandfather and I was like but let me
tell you that's not even a a scenario
you can fathom in your mind put your
kid's gonna miss this person she's never
I started crying I was like I do to her
you know and then it was just a cry Fest
the whole time dude I'll forget that
that um he's dead in certain situations
like what well like cuz we both there's
a couple things we both talked about
incessantly CU what what was his actual
date of uh death when did he pass 29th
of December 2022
21 yeah so coming up on two years coming
up on two years and you still feel some
habitual things like you forget well
what happens is like there's the things
that we would always um like talk like
you know we talked almost every day we
had a really good relationship with him
um but like certain things we would just
talk more about and it's like you know
stupid the way like uh college football
we were both he got me into it and then
and like the he would the way he would
like dude your A game is on and like you
know
interception taken back for like I'm
watching the game and he's watching it
he'll go uh did you did you see that
interception I'm yeah he goes yeah was
such a bad pass and I go and then he
just hang up the phone I was like he
wouldn't say anything he just hang up he
go all right hang up
like but these calls would happen
throughout a game and he would always
say did you see that for the game that
like he knows I'm like yeah of course I
[__] saw I'm watching the game dude
so but sometimes I would call him I'm
like you got to put on this other game
and so sometimes I'll be watching I'm
like oh I I gotta like I'll forget I'm
like oh he's yeah like I I'll forget in
that moment the other big thing that we
had like a huge affection with and it
like it's of course the way the universe
works it's crazy so my dad loved cars
he's just like an Enthusiast and it was
always like
articles uh you know do you see like
what they came out with for this like it
was just something that we would always
talk about cars cars cars and so and I
loved cars you know and I still do and
my youngest is the most obsessed child
I've ever seen like I Remember Loving
cars and his love of cars is really 50
times what mine is I mean he can
identify 40 manufacturers from their
logos Stella can do that it's really
crazy she really can and she's not into
cars but her brother is and she'll like
doson Toyota Subaru Hyundai I'm like
damn everything and then he likes to
start the cars and he's like does it
have a clutch and then he like can do it
with a clutch know about the clutch yeah
dude and then like everything every car
we see he goes is that a manual I'm like
no it's a [__] Corolla and he's like
that Emanual like no so every
car and so he um but so my dad and I
dude the other
day I don't know what it was I didn't
even tell him right but
like we were with Ellis and there's
something like Henry Ford
[__] Christina was like yeah he made
uh cars you know and she just goes you
can do anything and that's it like you
can do anything I started thinking about
Henry Ford I thinking about cars and I
started thinking about my dad and I got
to like put sunglasses on just all I
just it just all you know what I mean it
wasn't really yeah dude yeah I remember
that you know what's funny is that my
dad was a financial adviser and he was
always like
pretty
conservative like would would
encourage to be financially conservative
live below your
means you know he would tell me like you
shouldn't go to Starbucks so much you
know that adds up and I was like okay
and then one day I'm like like starting
to do well he's like you know what you
should get I go what he goes a plane a
[__] plane yeah a plane out of and
he's like he's like a lot of the PG guys
have one I'm like what the [__] are you
talking about man and he's like oh you
travel a lot I'm like get a private own
a plane and he's he's like you should
have your guys look into it I go I can't
believe I'm [__] talking to you right
now couple years later you know it was
always C right we're talking about cars
cars cars I go I ordered a I'm really
excited I ordered a car he's like what
are you getting I I'm getting a Porsche
he
goes you haven't thought about a Ferrari
and I'm like what I go no I want this
GT4 and he was like oh he's like you
should really look at
forar I'm like I think you want and that
was the truth is that he wanted that
hell yeah he did yeah every I can't the
funny thing is it sounds so crazy I
can't look because of some of those
conversations I can't look at a
Ferrari without thinking about him and
sometimes crying and people think I'm
mesmerized by you love this car she's
beautiful yeah I'm like yeah man I love
this [__] and I'm just thinking about
him yeah yeah how do you um how do you
keep them alive around the home and
stuff do you tell your kids stories
pictures up and all that you're your mom
obviously visits so you still have that
presence with him and stuff I think we
should do it more I mean everybody
like uh you know I mean I like telling
like the kids the the boys just love
[__] stories so they're like tell a poop
story and I'm like you know who's really
good at that your grandfather and I'll
tell them like when he [__] his pants at
the airport or on vacation and they
laugh hysterically and they're like does
Grandpa have more poop stories like yes
he
does so it sounds terrible but that's
one of the story like the lanes of
Stories We Tell about him who cares
that's keeping them alive for I saw I
saw him save a drowning girl I think
I've told you that before yeah how I
don't know if I remember that I went on
a trip with him when I was
uh I think it was six or seven we were
living in Ohio we fly down to Orlando
and uh there's a I still remember that
you ever go on a water slide where the
pressure of water when you hit the water
is talking about the
dura it's so intense yeah you get the
wedgie and they tell you to cross your
arms and tuck your chin or El but you
hit the water I'm saying when you enter
the water what is behind you coming on
top of you is really strong yes so like
it actually wave pushing you down yeah I
mean I went on one recently where I was
like holy [__] like 44 you know where
where is that this was in Texas on a
water slide where I was like man like
I'm talking about the entrance into the
water where you're like like gasping
because it it pushes you down well this
was like not at a water park this was
like at a hotel but I still remember
that when you hit the water that it was
like a
struggle to like it pushed you really
hard down I was on the swim team when I
was a young kid so like I was a pretty
proficient swimmer even at that age but
I remember being kind of
scared like I remember vividly being
like Oh my God like when you you ever
get caught in a wave and it tumbles you
and you you really feel like I'm never
coming up yes recently that happened to
me yes yes it is terrifying I it
recently did happen to me I was at the
[__] you pafic and it was just
throwing me around and I was like I'm
going to die yeah yeah
um it's so scary it's really [__]
pants are all that i' cut all over my
chest like it's just [__] theu down
there yeah like what the [__] they look
at you they're like y didn't see that
wave right there God damn they're like
why are you the only guy in there that's
what they nobody else is swimming you
idiot I remember the I my cousin was
like oh this Pacific's not as strong as
the Atlantic I'm like it's way stronger
so not even close you know how the
Pacific you know when when a wave
crashes you dive at the break so you can
go under it and through it well we were
doing that all day so long the waves
were so big and so powerful it [__]
our ears up gave us massive headaches
and he's like all right this is way
stronger out here I was like yeah this
where everybody [__] surfs and
everything yeah of course
um well I remember that pool and the
reason I make that distinction is
because I remember the fear that that
that I felt coming off that slide and
then a little while
later my dad was like looking into that
pool and just sees that there's somebody
at the bottom of the pool at the bot oh
they're just down there they're just
down there it was a girl uh who had come
off that slide got pushed down by that
that that water and was just at the
bottom of the pool he goes down pulls
her up puts her on the side and then
everybody starts surrounding her they
start doing CPR and then she survived
she damn hell yeah yeah that's great
that was cool and we watch we watched
last question what's that we watched
predator in the hotel you remember yeah
attched in your bra and then I was like
this is wild he's like don't tell your
mother that I let you see this I was
like okay oh that okay yeah um last
question and we're going to get out of
here I want to know this I think about
this one actually a lot you got 24 hours
with your dad what do you do how do you
spend good question
man I mean there's definitely a lot of
food involved because he'd loved to eat
you know I think about like I remember a
lot of his favorite like he loved
pancakes so I would take that dude for
pancakes for sure to start his day um he
was
like very much not into going far or
doing like we would take fatherson trips
and then we'd go out like you you get
breakfast and he like you want to go
back to the room I'm like we just
[__] got here that's all you'd want
to do yeah just sit in the room now and
then he wanted to retire and drive
everywhere yeah it's very Str like he
also had this like anxiety of like Get
it was always about getting back to the
like to the home you know like home safy
ready to go you ready to go back and
you're like I mean we just we just got
here he's like okay check it like you
know like this this nervous energy of
like let's just get back to where we
were the the the house or the hotel room
and then he's like that's the only time
I ever saw him like
relax um and khakis in a button-down
shirt that was his chill cloth yeah um
but I think it would be that I mean it
would probably honestly would be like
watch a college football game with him
that would be super f on TV and talk or
definitely on TV yeah I
mean yeah he would be he I mean I
remember going to games with him was the
worst it's like the third quarter he's
like you want to go so he wants to leave
the game like man it's a good game he's
like I know but there cars back to the
room Beat the Traffic no definitely on a
couch yeah um yeah just give him like
his favorite treats just see him enjoy
the the food he liked hangout um
honestly watch a game with him would be
like I think the best did he get to meet
both of your kids yes he did get to meet
them both yes he was obsessed yeah he
was obsessed he had this picture on his
phone of Ellis when he was like six
months old he's
smiling and over time my mom was like
why don't you change the picture he's
like I can't change this picture and he
would always show me he's like you see I
go yeah I remember he's like I got it
still like that's you can change it he's
like I would never change it like okay
but yeah he he loved being a Grand
Granddad there was only two right well
then Maria had two oh she has she has
two okay she has two so he had four he
got to meet all four kids oh that's good
that's good I got to be with all four
definitely love being a grand I mean
that's kind of like what he wanted to do
in yeah retirement was like go between
our houses and spend time with his
grandkids yeah it would have been that
the 24 hours would definitely yeah I
would eat it up for sure get him a
Ferrari yeah that's a good one you can
let them drive a Ferrari like I rented
it don't don't [__] crash mother
insurance is a fortune dude thank you
thank you for coming on I love you I
love you too man thank you for this um
plug whatever whatever you want uh yeah
you know see me on tour listen to the
podcast you know where to go ymh Studios
Tom cigar.com
um thank you thank you very much anytime
uh thank you all as well as always Ryan
on all social media ryan.com
come see me on tour all tickets at
ransler
[Music]
[Applause]